what's up i'm chadwick boseman and I'm  here in New York shooting with GQ for  the Man of the Year issue my mom I was  nominated for a woman of the year  because she always she's always come  under any pressure situation she's the  person to solve problems I grew up in  Anderson South Carolina I love the food  my mom makes the best sweet potato  souffle you've ever had I would nominate  kid president as Man of the Year thank  you because he's saving the world man  he's starting at a very young age my  song of the year is studio by Schoolboy  Q and BJ to Chicago kid my TV show of  the year is probably ray Donovan my ray  is funny if you can't laugh what are you  gonna do cry all the time  but I'll really root for Gotham don't  ever come back to Gotham my favorite  dance move of the year will have to be  TJ's Brown  and we have to be 2014 whirlwind whoa